let's say you're some type of a
hunter-gatherer and you're trying to
figure out how much of your time to
spend hunting and how much of your time
to spend gathering
so let's think about the different
scenarios here and the trade-offs that
they involve and just for simplicity
we're going to assume that when you're
talking about hunting the only animal
around you to hunt for are these little
rabbits and when we talk about gathering
the only thing that you can gather are
some type of berries that'll keep our
conversation a little bit simpler so
let's think about all of the scenarios
so first let's call this first scenario
scenario
a
and let's say
so let's call this the number of rabbits
the number of rabbits you can get and
then let's call this the number of
berries
let's do this column is the number of
berries that you can get so if you were
to spend your entire day going after
rabbits all your free time out you know
making sure you have time to sleep and
get dressed and all of those type of
things let's say that you can actually
get five rabbits on average in a given
day but if you spend all your time
getting rabbits you're not going to have
any time to get berries so you're going
to be able to get zero berries now let's
say that you were to only try to let's
say you were to allocate a little bit
more time to get berries and a little
bit less time to get rabbits so we'll
call that scenario b
we'll call scenario b
the reality where you have enough time
to get four rabbits on average and when
you do that all of a sudden you're able
to get a hundred you're able to get a
hundred berries and when we do the these
different scenarios we're assuming that
everything else is equal you're not
changing the amount of time you have
either hunting or gathering you're not
changing the amount of sleep you're not
changing your techniques for hunting
rabbits or hunting berries or you're not
somehow looking to do other things with
your time so all other things are equal
and the general term for this and it
sounds very fancy if you were to say it
in a conversation is ceteris paribus
ceteris
ceteris paribus
paribus which literally means so anytime
someone says oh and you know ceteris
paris we assume this variable changes or
whatever else they're saying we're
assuming everything else is being held
equal so ceteris
ceteris means
ceteris means all other things
other
other things
you're probably familiar with etc
same word essentially other things in
paribus
paribus other things equal so you're not
when you're going from scenario a to
scenario b you're not changing the
amount of time you're sleeping you're
not changing
somehow the geography where you are
you're in a dramatic way you're not
changing uh you're not changing the
tools you use or the technology
everything else is equal the only
variable you're changing is how much
time you allocate to finding rabbits
versus finding berries so let's do some
more scenarios assuming ceteris paribus
so let me do scenario c
you could on average have enough time to
get three rabbits but if you get three
rabbits then all of a sudden you will
only be able to get or you will be able
to get or if you're only getting three
rabbits you're now looking to get 180
berries and let's do a couple more i'm
gonna do two more scenarios so let's say
scenario d
if you reduce the amount of time you
spend getting rabbits so you get two
rabbits now all of a sudden you can you
have enough time on average to get
240 berries and then
let's say
you spend even less time
let's say you spend even less time
getting hunting for rabbits on average
then you have even more time for berries
and so you're able to get 280 berries
and then i'll do one more scenario here
so let's say scenario f and let's call
these the scenarios scenarios
scenario a a through f so scenario f is
you spend all your time looking for
berries in which case on average you're
going to be able to get 300 berries a
day but since you have no time for
rabbits you aren't going to get any
rabbits so what i want to do is plot
these and on one axis i'll have the
number of rabbits on the other axis i'll
have the number of berries so let me do
it right over here
so this axis i will call this my
rabbit axis
rabbits
and we'll start that'll be zero and then
this will be
one
two
three
four and then that will be five rabbits
and then in this axis
this axis i will do the berries
i will do the berries so this right over
here let's make this
100 berries this is 200 berries
200 berries and then this is
300 berries and so this is my berries
my berry's axis
now let's plot these points these
different scenarios so first we have
scenario a
scenario a maybe i should do all these
colors in that scenario a color scenario
a five rabbits zero berries five rabbits
zero berries we are right over there
that is scenario a scenario b
scenario b four rabbits a hundred
berries four rabbits one hundred berries
that's right over there that's a hundred
berries so that is scenario b
scenario c
scenario see three rabbits 180 berries
three rabbits 180 let's see this would
be 150 180 will be like right over there
so three
if you have time for three rabbits you
have time for about 180 berries on
average so this is scenario
c
and then scenario d we have in white if
you have time for two rabbits you have
time for 240 berries so that is right
around there
so this is scenario d because this is to
fit actually a little bit lower
so this would be 250 so 240 is a little
bit lower than that so it'll be like
right over there that is scenario d
scenario e
you have if you have time for one rabbit
you have time for 280 berries so that
gets us right about
right about there that is scenario e and
then finally scenario f you are spending
all of your time looking for berries you
have no time for rabbits so all of your
time for berries no time for rabbits
zero rabbits 300 berries that's right
over there so this is scenario f
so what all of these points represent
these are all points and now this is
going to be a fancy word but it's a very
simple idea these are all points on you
as a hunter gatherer on your production
possibilities frontier because if we
draw a line i just arbitrarily picked
these scenarios although i guess you
could on average get four and a half
rabbits on average on average get three
and a half rabbits and then you'd have a
different number of berries so these are
all points on the different combinations
between the trade-offs of rabbits and
berries let me connect all of these let
me collect them in a color that i
haven't used yet so let me connect them
and what you see
it should just be one curve so i'll do
it as a dotted line it's easier for me
to draw a dotted curve than a straight
curve
so this right over here
this curve right over here represents
all the possible possibilities of
combinations of rabbits and berries i've
only picked certain of them but you
could have a scenario right over here
maybe we could call that scenario g
where on average the amount of time
you've allocated on average you would
get four and a half rabbits so some days
you'd get four rabbits then every other
day you'd get five rabbits so maybe it
averages out to four and a half rabbits
and then maybe it looks like you would
get about 50 berries in that situation
so all of these are possibilities you
don't have to just jump from four
rabbits to five rabbits or maybe you
know you're spending maybe in this
scenario you're spending
seven hours and this scenario spent
eight hours but you could spend seven
hours in a minute or seven hours in a
second so anything in between is
possible and all of those possibilities
all of those possibilities are on this
curve so these five scenarios actually
these six scenarios that we've talked
about so far these are just these are
just scenarios on
on this curve and that curve we call
once again fancy term simple idea
our production
production possibilities
possibilities
i've put two eyes in there by accident
possibilities frontier
because it shows all of the different
possibilities we can do we can get three
rabbits and 180 berries two rabbits and
240 berry and 240 berries what we cannot
do is something that's beyond this so
for example we can't get a scenario like
this so this right over here would be
impossible impossible let me scroll over
to the right a little bit
let me scroll
see my scrolling thing okay
so this right over here is impossible
this point right over here where i'm
getting five rabbits and 200 berries if
i'm getting five rabbits i'm spending
all my time on rabbits i have no time
for berries or another way to think of
it if i'm getting 200 berries i don't
have enough time to get five rabbits so
this point is impossible this point
would be impossible any point that's on
this side of the curve is impossible
now any any point that's on this side of
the curve you can kind of view this
inside the curve or below the curve or
to the left of the curve all of these
points right over here are possible
all of these points right over here are
these points for example it is very easy
for me to get one rabbit and 200 berries
so that right over there is possible now
is that optimal no because if i were to
really work properly i could i could get
i could get many more berries or i could
get more rabbits for if i have 200
berries i could get more rabbits or if
i'm concerned if i only want one rabbit
i can get more berries so this is
possible all of the points are down here
are possible but they aren't optimal
they are not efficient so the points in
here the points in here will say that
they are not
efficient maybe somehow i'm not using my
resources optimally to to do this type
of thing when i'm over here or maybe i'm
just not being optimally uh focused or
whatever it might be if you're talking
about a factory setting when you're
talking about maybe deciding to make one
thing or another then maybe you just
aren't using your the the resources in
an optimal way now all the points on the
frontier
these are efficient you're doing the
most you can do right now we're not
making any judgment between whether any
of these possibilities are better than
any other possibility all we are saying
is that you are doing the most that you
can do any of these things you are
making the most use of your time